I'll wait a few seconds here until we go
live over to YouTube
I think we've just gone live over to
YouTube right now
hi everybody
so nice to see you all today or at least
see your names over on YouTube live
welcome to the posit Enterprise
Community Meetup
I'm Rachel I lead our customer Community
here at posit this is a friendly and
open Meetup environment for teams to
share use cases teach lessons learned
and just meet each other and ask
questions
if you've joined us here at the Meetup
before put a 2 into the YouTube chat if
this is your first time put a one into
the chat
I stole that from Matt dancho
um but for those of us who have been
here before I encourage you to also help
welcome everybody in
together we're all dedicated to making
this space inclusive and open for
everyone no matter your experience
industry or background
during the event we will certainly have
time for a q a and you're able to ask
questions Live on YouTube live through
the chat and I can see them and save
them and star them here but also
anonymously through slido which I will
share on the screen in just a second
here
our presenters today also have a few
questions for you too so there will be a
poll
um through slido as well so I'll put
that onto the screen there
to address one of the popular questions
up front yes the recording will be
available and it will actually be ready
right as the presentation ends so at the
same exact YouTube live link
but anyways I am so excited to have you
all here with us today at posit we get
to see firsthand the shift to open
source across the pharmaceutical
industry and are excited to be able to
share some of those stories with you all
through through meetups and all kinds of
stories
um I'm joined by my colleague Jason
Mills who is helping out in the
background as well Jason works with many
of our life science customers today
thank you Jason for joining and helping
out
we are so excited to have both Gabriella
rustici and Guillaume desashi here with
us today to share their experience and
learn more about the our journey that
AstraZeneca is currently on
Gabriella is data science learning
senior director in astrazeneca's r d
data science and AI where she is
responsible for developing a strategy
for and creating a centralized approach
to data science learning for r d
eom is a statistical science director at
AstraZeneca passionate about helping
bring new medicines to patients by
leveraging the power of statistics and
precision medicine
he has also been leading a team of 15
collaborators focused on building the
community of our users at AstraZeneca
called r at AZ
thank you both so much for joining us
today and I love to pull you up on stage
with me here
can you hear us okay
hi everyone yeah hi everyone
thank you so much for joining us I'm
gonna head backstage but I'll be
collecting all the questions and and
resources and sharing in the chat too
and I will turn it over to you both
fantastic so thank you thank you very
much Rachel for having us today
it's a great pleasure for us to be here
and it's a great pleasure for me to be
to be sharing this experience with
Gabriella so before we get started we
actually have a couple of questions and
uh Rachel will be sharing a slider link
with all of you because we want to get
to know you even if we are not in the
same room we want to get to know who you
are want to get to know what you are
connecting from uh so yeah please please
answer the questions in slider
and we'll leave it about 30 min 30
seconds to one minute
and I put the link in the YouTube chat
but it's also on the screen here the
short link for the the slido
perfect thank you very much Rachel
and I guess people can answer directly
um in the slider right
foreign
and and I want you to picture a scene
you you are learning a new programming
language
and I won't tell you how long ago I
first started learning how to program in
SAS because both gabri and I decided
okay let's not disclose it it might be
embarrassing
but you first learn to
um use this programming language and for
me it was actually SAS and back then ah
kind of felt like a far away land kind
of like this person in this picture it
was like a magnificent landscape we knew
we were having fun uh with us hours all
the way back there and I'm mentioning it
because I think there's been a
two-parting shift in the pharmaceutical
industry and back when I learned how to
use SAS I think there was a strong
divide between South and all and you
basically had to choose your Camp either
you were a SAS user or you were or on
our user
but I think things have really changed
in the industry and other things are
really different because you can read an
actual SAS data set from R and there is
real interconnection between the two
languages so that's one thing but the
other thing that I find very interesting
is that our Workforce the new
uh people that we hire
they're actually multilingual they speak
different programming languages and most
of them they speak are answers or R and
another one and that's what is really
fun
but talking a bit more about
our Workforce and the profiles of our
users
I think we can we can think of these
Usual Suspects because we can think of
the statisticians we can think of the
programmers we can think of the data
scientists
but what is very interesting is that VR
users are AstraZeneca it's actually much
more than The Usual Suspects because
we've got clinicians using all we've got
medical directors using our we've got
information practice scientists using R
so we've got a lot of people using our
and it is this diversity which makes it
very fun
so before I head over to gabri
there is one slider question that we
would want you to enter
and this question is about how you first
learned how to use r
and again let's let's wait a bit I can
see I can try and pull your screen on to
see to show it let's see
cool
and I know that there's a few quite a
few of you back there
so let's wait to have at least 30 people
answering this
Okay so
so water so gabri you've got you've got
the answer to your question you wanted
to know how people had first learned how
to use r
well it seems like a lot of people are
self-taught our users that they actually
never followed any kind of formal
training
gabri and I think
yeah yes indeed thank you and I don't
think this is a different you know from
from what I had expected actually I know
uh
um lots of programmers uh self-teach
themselves how to program not everybody
is fortunate in their workplace or
throughout their career to have a
wonderful dedicated Learning and
Development team uh as we are fortunate
in the snai here at AstraZeneca so I
just wanted to put up faces and names
because you know and this is this is the
team that makes our training program
possible develops it runs it and also
our community initiative
as well so maybe you'll find some of
these people on on LinkedIn and you
you'll connect with them let's just say
that although you know the the success
of our program is also linked to the
father we have a very large group of
trainers years I've seen or Abhijit
connected is one of them so again a
training program wouldn't be possible if
it wasn't for the time and commitment
that the instructors give us so let's
move to the next slide what do I write I
um so the Learning and Development team
that I represent aligns their activities
and initiatives to the 3E framework so
we all know that the best way of
learning is through experiencing
something to being exposed to others and
and the way that others work and connect
and the smallest component should be
education you know but often education
might help us get us started to gain a
little bit of confidence to then go out
there and experience and expose
themselves the way others are working so
let's just start taking a look at the
education program that we run and if we
move to the next Slide the project that
I lead within AstraZeneca is called data
science Academy so data science academy
is an r d wide educational resource in
everything that pertains data science
and AI you can already imagine that our
feature prominently in these so what we
try to do is to cater to all of the
needs of the people that Guillaume had
onizes last slide so we recognize that
there are many different individuals in
different roles with different needs
some that requires you know a little bit
of data science awareness some that
require deep technical skills to carry
out their role
but let's also keep in mind that uh we
this is not just about Technical
Training this is also about how do we
bridge the gap between scientists and
data scientists how do we improve the
way that we communicate and we try to
tailor everything to the needs of our
therapy areas and functions so again you
relate to to training better if we are
using examples that are close to your
heart so this is a nutshell is what data
science academy is and if we move to the
next uh slide as I said before we
recognize the fact that there are many
aspects of data scientists science some
that are more relevant to scientists
some that are more relevant to data
science this is sort of how we think and
organize our activity we have awareness
raising Level Training the where there
is no coding it's just more about
understanding how is data science used
uh ethical aspect or working responsibly
with data and artificial intelligence
and maybe for the bravest to start
dipping their toes into coding if you
look at the right hand side of of the
slide instead this is you know the
component of the train that is more
technical so learning how to use R how
to use Python then start applying this
programming language in the context of
Statistics in the context of machine
learning how do we move them to the next
level and adopt coding best practices so
that we can collaborate and share coding
effectively and then for example how we
use R in the analysis or transcriptomics
data analysis proteomics data so looking
at the analysis of particular data types
so and in the middle that very important
crucial
connector that is how do we translate
between these two
expertises so what makes us better
Communicator better collaborator what
the basic knowledge do we need in order
to carry out our job more uh most
effectively
moving to the next slide we also
recognize the fact that we all learn
differently some people are more akin to
self-study
and for the reason we have uh several
educational resources that are available
to our e-learning platform they are
curated by subject matter expert within
the organization and we sort of bring to
them a digested set of learning Pathways
to get them started in many of the
topics that we discussed about our best
selling point is indeed our portfolio
virtual instructor-led courses so this
is your traditional classroom experience
although we do a lot of our activities
virtually still until we we go back to
the face-to-face these are your
multi-days courses a mixture of lectures
and practicals uh
and where you have obviously the
possibility of interacting with the
trainer interacting with uh a a mentor
um and further your uh knowledge by
starting to experience by doing
exercises and this is where also our
existing collaboration with the posit
Academy lies because we have done and
delivered some training in collaboration
with them around basic art training and
then we bleed even more into the
experiential learning although I won't
talk too much about this today with our
apprenticeship program some of our
project-based work and some of our
mentoring again thinking about how do we
learn on the job how do we learn by
concentrating on specific projects that
are offered to our learner and how do we
learn by talking to Mentor somebody once
you have done with a course how do you
start implementing some of the things
that you have learned perhaps you need a
little bit more steer that's where our
mentoring program which is very much
running collaboration with Community
already that the Geo will tell talk to
us about later
and I think I have possibly one more uh
slide which is the next one just by
looking and reiterating the fact that
our training is a major component of our
virtual and stratulate courses I
launched data science academy shortly
after joining AstraZeneca in 2020 so
we'll be running our program since then
and actually the art training is
probably the first training that we
offer uh 41 of our courses focus on our
as I said before we range from basic
programs statistical analysis machine
learning analytics and we have until now
maybe these figures are already a little
bit older uh maybe your visit my
personal sneak a course in there since I
put this slides together last but we
offer in the excess of 900 prices on our
virtual instructor-led courses lots of
training for SAS programmers
learning to use R we have done a
specific training program for them and
we also also have a few Learners on our
online learning platform but the virtual
structural courses are preferred and as
you see there is a little bit of glimpse
of what our Learners say after six
months from attending a course attend us
have definitely improved their coding
skills are definitely improve their
ability to handle data so we we can
definitely see a tangible effects of
Learners attending courses but then also
start implementing uh what they learn on
their day-to-day job and you know once
individuals we have obviously
geographically distributed Learners
graduate from some of our courses often
what they do next is also join our
communities as I said to continue
learning from their peers and this is
where I'll pass the ball back to
guillauma which will tell us a bit more
about our fabulous our community
thank you very much Gabby thank you
thank you for dinner this nice
introduction about about the great work
that you've been doing
and I think you you said something very
nice regarding the diversity in the way
we learn and I think it's it's very true
and if we think a bit about it some of
us are going to be liking learning by
watching videos some of us is going to
be by opening a book some of us is going
to be by being in the classroom even
though these days it's it's a bit harder
to be in a physical classroom
and the way I kind of like to think
about these things is with two indices
so the first one I'm calling it The
self-led Learning index
and at the top of it it means that you
are going to be learning by yourself
it's a bit like if you are going to be
opening a book
and at the bottom of it people are going
to be taking you by the hand someone is
going to be helping you out
so this is the first index the self-led
learning index
and then there's the synchronicity index
on the right hand side if you miss the
event it's too bad you won't be able to
catch up but on the left hand side you
are going to be able to catch up because
these kind of events or this kind of
training is asynchronous
and now going back to what Gary was
actually talking about we can fit the
various kind of trainings and virus kind
of resources in these four credentials
and if we think about the steps of the
resources they are very much
asynchronous and they are very much
self-led
by their name
then if we think about the virtual
instructor-led courses
someone is seeking you by the hand you
are not in the classroom per se not
physically but still someone is helping
you out
and last but not least we've got the
experiential learning opportunities
so these three kind of trainings that
gabri was referring to we can place them
on the credit one and we can already see
that while tapping onto this diversity
of learning and that not every single
learning is going to be carried out the
same way and I think that is the
strength of what garbage team garbage
Learning and Development team is doing
so before we move into the community I
would want to ask you one question
is there on our community in your
organization
and I saw that about more than 50 of you
answered the question
the previous question so let's aim for
at least 50 this time again
okay pretty cool thank you thank you for
your answers
it's pretty cool to see that there is an
arc community in a
um in quite a proportion of the ones
attending
and that's also pretty cool to see that
for some of you like 20 plus percent
um there's something in the works or you
would like to start one which is also
really exciting
So yeah thank you for your answer so
let's let's move on with the community
of our users at AstraZeneca
so the way we called it we called it rad
and as with all things
um related to how we decided okay if we
are going to be doing in our community
we are going to have some X stickers and
this is the logo of rwg
now when we started it
um and when we started it I'm talking
about the early days but the early days
were not that long ago it was a bit more
than a year and a half ago
a few of us got together
and we brainstormed and we were like
okay what could we do to get a community
of our users started
and we jotted on some ideas and one of
them was what about a tidy Tuesday
another one of them was what about a
weekly blog post
and another one of them was what about
an internal art conference
now we knew that it was going to be
taking time
and that every single idea every single
idea on a piece of paper was going to be
taking a whole lot of time but we were
still like okay let's explore these
ideas
and the first one
we started was something that we brought
it as easy tidy Tuesday
so if you've heard of Tidy Tuesday easy
tidy Tuesday is sealing with pride tidy
Tuesday
but we made it our very own and and when
I say we made it our very own basically
what we did is that each time we were
promoting a data set a publicly
available data set
we were framing it we were telling a
story around something going on
internally within AstraZeneca
one of our values are framing it around
something going on externally
and this was happening once a month
and the way we were doing this we were
promoting the data set we were promoting
the story on our internal social media
which is something which is your body by
Facebook so it's a bit like a Facebook
equipment or internal social media you
can see it as a Facebook equivalent
so we were promoting this data set
collaborate has had about two weeks to
submit the entry
and a few days after the deadline we
were actually promoting one of the
entries and there was a featured
contributor and what you can see in here
is the featured contributor of the very
last AZ tidy Tuesday because after 25
editions we decided to retire easy
target Tuesday
so this is something of the past
now let me go back to this let me go
back to the diversity of learning easy
tidy Tuesday feeds on the top left
because you can go back in time all the
codes all the images on the graphs are
actually stored on a SharePoint online
so if you want to go back in time you
can go back to Edition number one and
you can go back to the code of that
given person by Edition number one
and it's a mix of self-led learning
index and
and also people mooking you by the hand
because we were doing some code review
for every single entry from the first
few editions of Tidy Tuesday
so that's for easy tidy Tuesday
but
as I was saying very early on we're like
okay maybe we could organize an internal
art conference we knew it was going to
be a big piece but we also knew that it
would it was going to be good for the
community
and if we think about it
a conference is pretty much a
synchronous kind of thing because if you
miss it
you're going to be losing a lot of the
interactivity and then it's a mix
between self-led and people taking you
right ahead
but in a nutshell it was a hard day
event we had 10 plus hours of content
related to our 30 speakers 30 close to
30 bosses
and and all of these from close to 100
authors
and we were very fortunate to have
Mexican
um so now if I'm posit formerly known as
as R studio so that was that was pretty
cool and you know it was the first time
we were doing this so we didn't know how
it was going to be received we didn't
know if people were going to be showing
up
we were blown away and actually the
feedback was Stella
and we had more than 500 participants in
this internal conference
so seeing these were like okay we can't
we can't just stop here we have to keep
going we have to keep
promoting new initiatives we have to
keep inventing initiatives and that's
what we did in 2022
and one of these initiatives is the r
function of the month
so the concept is that we detail one our
function and what we are actually mean
Daniel here because this is led by
Daniel and he does this in the form of
the blog post
it happens once a month
and again we leverage our internal
social media so on our intern on social
media we do a workplace post a Facebook
post
and that's actually how it looks like so
it's an Old MacDonald it's a DOT HTML
and people can go back to it there's a
nice description description and for
example in this one it was about five or
longer and pyrod wider and these chunks
of code so that people can
basic consult this and learn about these
function about these given package at
their own later
so that's the r function of the month
and if we go back to this then this is
pretty much some flood because you are
going to have to make the effort to go
through this HTML
but you can pretty much go back in time
because it's very easy to consult this
and to have a look at this
now another initiative that we kicked
out this year
um and this is led by Gustav sodastrem
is something that we're calling the
launch Androids and the whole idea of
the luncheon lens is that we know that
time is cause
so we decided okay let's tackle one
Topic at a time and let's have 30 minute
sessions so about a 20 minute
presentation five ten minutes q a
and same thing happening once a month
and having inclusion in mind while
alternating between the US and Europe
and we've got so far these kind of
events we had a mix of internal speakers
and external speakers
and for example in here we had a
presentation from
who is one of our collaborators and she
talked about gladly but some other
people called about our McDonalds some
other people
um talked about many other topics about
packages that they had developed so
that's the lunch and learns
and again the luncheoners are very much
synchronous events because if you miss
this it's going to be hard
you're going to be able to catch up but
you will again lose the interactivity
now let me move on to to something that
we brought it as the Ten to ones
so the ten two ones are led by Tom Tom
Marlow and the idea with these was okay
we need to Federate this community
and we want people to get to know each
other
so let let's ask
to our users
10 questions and each month is going to
be the exact same 10 questions
and again it's once a month and in here
you can you can see the layout of the 10
to ones so this was from a few months
ago
and what I really like with this
initiative is that you can you can flip
through the different 10 towards like
like you would flip through a marketing
and you can see the diversity
um and and and that's where you you see
that everyone learns differently
everyone has different kinds of tips
um on how to learn art
and if we look at this the tent wants
you can pretty much go back in time
because you can be okay I'm going to be
catching up on the 10 pass editions I'm
going to be tripping through the
magazine of the 10 to ones
um and anytime I would say people are
going to be taking you by the hand
because the tips are very precise so
it's it's a jam because you can you can
very easily apply these to your
day-to-day work
and initially I was saying that we were
leveraging our internal social media
and that we were doing all our
Communications via our internal social
media and this was true until very
recently and again it's a question of
inclusion and diversity because we know
that not everyone is checking our
internal social media
so we decided okay let's launch a
monthly newsletter and true you dang is
the one leading this
and the idea is a newsletter so you've
got all news internal and external it's
one single email who are not spamming
you and it's happening
once a month by the middle of the month
and this is how it looks and basically
she is collating everything that has
happened in the past month every single
hour are the easy initiative that has
happened in the past month
and so what has been going on internally
externally
is there let's say on Pharma is there a
Meetup coming up these kind of things
so now let's go back to this
the newsletter pretty much fits in here
but that's not it because we've got
other kinds of initiatives and one of
them we are calling it let's meet each
other and again it goes back to getting
to know each other because I think at
the end of the day that's all that
matters we want us human beings We crave
these connections we want to know each
other we want to build connections with
other people and then these connections
I'm gonna be helping building
connections across departments so that's
what is let's meet each other it's a
very informal get-together it's a 30
minute session
you connect you don't connect doesn't
matter and and you get to meet other all
users in the organization sometimes we
talk about all sometimes we talk about
other things one thing we discussed for
example was uh how do you what do you
think about about the new name what do
you think about posit another time we
talked about the holidays another time
we talked about our favorite our package
so plenty of things
and then recently we also did
um some workshops jointly with posit and
we've done two so far and um we are very
much looking forward to be doing more
with budget because they were very well
received in the organization
and last but not least the very
um the latest initiative that we
launched is something that we called the
azr hotdesk and the whole idea in here
is you you come with your question it's
a face-to-face kind of event
you come with your question
um and we're going to be helping you uh
to answer these are related questions
so that's what we're doing in the
community of our users
now
of course all of these initiatives and
in total we've got in 2022 we had eight
initiatives going on at the same time
now we've got seven because tidy Tuesday
easy tidy Tuesday retired but I won't
lie
it does take quite a substantial amount
of time
but behind the scenes I'm the one doing
the talking today but behind the scenes
there's a
great team working fabulously
and they did an amazing job throughout
the year and I don't think we would be
here today without that education
without their passion and without their
commitment
so I want to thank them
um if you want to know more about the
community we've written a blog post
which is available on the deposit blog
so you can type this on your favorite
browser and you'll be able to find this
otherwise you can Flash the QR code and
you'll you will also land right there
so before we wrap up we've got
another question for you
what is more valuable for you at this
moment in time
and again let's let's aim for 50.
okay Sam
so it's
I would say you know like every once you
have best of of Both Worlds so they want
to have
um what what God represented and and
potentially a bit of community as well
so I think um gabri I I've got a
question for you so we talked about what
we did in 2022
uh both in terms of trainings and you
talked about the importance of the
diversity of learnings with um education
education experience and exposure but
what is on your wish list for 2023 well
again things is uh we we can train lots
of people on how to use R but then we
need to make sure that people use the
skill that they have acquired use it or
lose it so how do we make sure that
there are opportunities for them to do
so how do we make sure that there are
projects lined up once
the skill has been acquired how do we
make sure actually that lots of the
training that we develop is developed in
response to the need of a particular
group a particular function a particular
set of individuals so the requests come
to us like it has been for the
development of our training for the SAS
programmers we evaluate what the
training needs is and we develop an
intervention that I'm not going to say
guarantees but where we have some Metric
successes from the beginning of how are
we going to embed the skill what is it
that we are aiming to achieve through
this training
and then we are obviously looking at the
opportunity of strengthening our
collaboration with posit so we're
actually been discussing to Second
someone from posit to AstraZeneca to
better understand some of their our
learning needs and developing some
solutions so we're really looking
forward to this opportunity for 2023.
maybe I'm curious of asking you the same
question what is on your wish list for
2023
well thank you very much gabri
um
I I think for me it's going to be is
going to be the connections and and I'm
gonna be making the parallel with the
picture I I showed at the beginning
I think we are in a very nice place at
the moment because we've got more and
more connection connections between
South and all uh that's one thing and
there's more and more connections
between the various languages it doesn't
matter if it's us or so that's one thing
now the other thing I'm very much
looking forward to in 2023 is all the
connections that are going to be made
to the voice departments other
Schwarzenegger and we often talk about
how do we evaluate a community and how
hard it is to actually evaluate a
community
I think all these connections at the end
of the day do you have the business do
you help the organization because if you
know that your friend that you met uh
let's meet each other or that you met at
any other kind of event is also working
on developing let's say a shiny app but
you've never done this then you might be
able to reach out to that person instead
of learning it the hard way so that's
what I'm very much looking forward to in
2023 so it's these Bridges these
connections between people and between
departments
foreign
for having us today
see lots of questions Rachel oh I was
muted thank you so much for for joining
us Gabrielle it's really amazing to hear
about all the different ongoing
initiatives at AstraZeneca and about
this growing Community too I I see a lot
of love for AstraZeneca in the chat and
a few people from your team on as well
there are so many great questions here
um so I love to see if we can get to as
many as possible I think we might have
like over 30 questions here though so
we'll do our best
um but let me actually I'll pull over a
question from the YouTube chat
right now is trying to Star some of them
how we were as we were going
um but one question
from Jeremy was AZ team is there a
company-wide community for data science
or is it only in research
woman
so I can I can take this one I can talk
about the our community so so one thing
that I did not mention is that
today I talked about the r Community but
we actually have
um other communities so there is for
example an Imaging Community there is
for example a python community so the r
Community is not the only community
now going going
um entering Jeremy's question
the community is an astronautical wide
community so that's why it was and it is
important for us to have these diverse
sets of initiatives so that we try to
meet the needs of everyone and and when
you think about it it's actually not
that easy because if you see it in r d
if you sit in research and and
development then when you think of a
topic intuitively you're going to be
thinking of a topic which is research
and development oriented
so I think you have to be proactive and
you have to make conscious decisions so
that you include everyone
I see on slido there is a question that
got a lot of upvotes so I think people
are really feeling seen in this question
how do people at AstraZeneca find
balance between training versus doing
their actual job and how is ashrazeneca
leadership supported and enabled this
balance
I think it's an interesting question
finding balance at the end of the year
is what everybody's looking for but I
think I have to say you know this is it
is always a tricky question
but I definitely have to say that
AstraZeneca leadership has been very
supportive
particularly when it comes to specific
programs that we have developed we are
buying from them from the beginning in
helping us steer the development of some
of these programs as well we do try to
raise
awareness of line managers of the
importance of ring fencing time for
Learning and especially encourage now
that we have all of these resources and
opportunity people to think about uh how
training can help them achieve goals in
their individual development plans so we
can improve that because we haven't
necessarily find the perfect balance but
I have to say that there is is a support
from leadership is there and I think is
quite crucial to make sure that these
training programs land and people have
the chance of taking advantage of them
thank you and I just wanted to remind
everybody real quickly that if you're
looking for where everybody's asking
these questions we have a slido link
uh and I just put the link on the screen
and we can share it again in the chat
but you can also upvote some of the
other questions so they come up to the
top too
another popular question I see was from
Dan over on slido was there any issue
with Regulators FDA EMA when you switch
to R from SAS
no man I'm happy to give you the go-to
this one and and got briefly free to to
complete uh if you want
so
I think so we've not made a complete
switch to all there are other companies
in the industry that
um decided to make this um leap
uh We've not made it yet
um for a variety of reasons we've not
made that yet and I think
whether we like it or not and I'm not
saying us as [ __ ] as an industry SAS is
going to remain a key player in in the
years to come
and again for a variety of reasons
because if we take it can be as well it
can be any other from our company
if you've got SAS macros if you've got
sales programs that are developed is
going to be taking quite a substantial
amount of time before you are you can
actually transition to another kind of
programming language it can be all it
can be jury I can it doesn't matter
um so we've not completely made that
shift
um and and I think if we do decide to
make that shift it's going to take a bit
of time however in our workflows what we
see is that there is more and more
people using a wide variety of languages
do you want to do you want to compliment
Gabby no I think uh very much agree with
with what you say Guillaume I think
there is uh I think a recognition anyway
that Regulators are now fully aware of
Art and the power of R so things will
change in the future and you know for
the moment as Guillaume said we are
doing some of the the validate some of
the work in our and getting people
prepared for that switch basically and
when it happens you might be the first
one to know
thank you
another question over on slido was a
challenge I find is having Enterprise
tools for our available for people to
use after learning or training how have
you dealt with this at AstraZeneca
so uh I think our we have a several
platforms that are available to our data
scientists and and researchers I mean r
is obviously one of the tools that can
be easily installed from from our
software store so anybody can install if
it's installed we have an art studio
server uh you know we have Computing
resources where R is available so
depending on your preferred way of work
I would say that you and and Gian please
uh
disagree with me if I am wrong but
depending on on the way that you prefer
to work there should be a solution
available for you and you should
definitely be able to have access to to
R through these various platforms that
are available
okay
and in fact what we try to do in some
courses is already around the training
on such platforms so that then the
transition is is even seamless
I also like to add if anybody is curious
if their team had access to those and
just didn't know because I know that's
hard across huge organizations feel free
to reach out to me if you ever want me
to connect you with your account team
here at posit too
I'll at some point I'll put my LinkedIn
in in the chat too
but a lot of uh collapse in the chat for
you and people saying very inspiring
talk thank you so much I see Joshua has
asked thank you both Guillaume and
Gabriella for this excellent talk I'm
curious as to what role machine learning
with r has an r d at AstraZeneca
that is a good question again do you
want to take it or they want me to
reflect on the the no training side of
things you can I I can let you reflect
on on the training side of things and I
can compliment yeah
so actually
um it is true that by default one would
think machine learning equals python uh
and it's possibly very true that uh
um lots of our data scientists uh that
are working in machine learning uh might
have chosen python uh I can say that the
first course that we offer in machine
learning was machine learning
through some of my former collaborators
at the University
of of Cambridge
um but
Dion maybe you have a different take
I I agree with you and and I'm going to
be alluding I can't remember who said
that our Informer but I think you know
in in 2022 I think what is important is
that we've got a set of tools we've got
historically in the industry in the
pharmaceutical industry has been SAS so
we've got SAS we've got our we've got
python some of us use Julia I think
depending on on what you do and
depending on the requirements from the
regulatory authorities then you've got
this set of tools and and you you can
tap on one tool on the other
um and and I don't think and I think
that's actually quite important I don't
think we should limit ourselves to one
programming language because some
programming one programming language is
going to be having some strength then um
that they are that doesn't have
and and again I think it it goes back to
to personal preference some of us like
like better during machine learning with
r and some of us like better doing
machine learning with python depends on
what you are the most comfortable with
as long as you get the job done you know
thank you
see a few questions that touch upon a
similar idea but one was with the
astrazeneca's data science academy be
available to public to the public to
gain the expertise
and maybe I'll also ask are there any
other Community Resources you recommend
too
in the plants that we currently have
the resource itself it's it's only an
in-house resource what I can say though
is
I am actually working on some training
activity more in the format of Summer
Schools or winter schools where we can
actually bring together
academics and and and and colleagues
from AstraZeneca I think you know that
is what I I personally as a training
organizer I miss very much in organizing
events that are virtual you know the the
the lack of that networking component so
I'm currently working on a summer school
for next year to take place in Cambridge
that will be open to academic and and
and and member of the private sector so
opportunities like that are really
looking forward to open more up in the
future and it's you know sort of similar
The Same Spirit some of our community
activities we also invite external
speaker and really try to uh increase
the flow between our you know from
knowledge and networking opportunity uh
between our
um uh academic industry let's not forget
you know that there are many other
progress that we did not talk about
today you know we are PHD programs we
have internship programs so there are
other opportunities where uh we we can
create you know collaborations so I
would say probably stay tuned for the
first AZ summer school
love it that's awesome
okay let me see going through some of
the slido questions somebody else asked
how do you determine which people go
through posit Academy versus in-house
training our team is exploring Academy
now
uh so I think actually it's an
interesting question so we were actually
some of the beta testers of posit
Academy so we were one of the first uh
to take advantage of of the program and
I think you know I don't know how much
the the people on online know about
posit Academy but I think one of the
strengths of this program is that the
training it's it's a development built
around a particular project or a
particular objective so the individuals
that kind of applied to attend that
course and needed to also propose a
project uh that they would work on and
and that around which the training was
crafted so I think we went on selecting
individuals that had also quite a timely
need to learn are they they need to
implement the skill we try to also
guarantee sort of an equal
representation of participants from our
different research areas so that was
kind of the approach that we used so we
actually do not normally do selection
for participate on the courses where in
these cases we did so that we wanted to
get you know so the most motivated
individual with the uh most pressing
need to acquire the skill and with the
project line up to apply these two so
um
uh I would say selection was quite key
in this case and and we would continue
to run this collaboration in in the
spirit selecting part is not a would
mostly benefit
thank you
is it okay if I keep firing away a a few
more questions at you okay
so
um going by some of the most upvoted
questions here in slido one was how do
you do risk analysis for any tasks you
are doing uh first time in R and
submission studies
oh this one is yours
thank you thank you very much
moral support all the way
um so such the best of my knowledge and
so as I was saying we've not made
different transition uh to all of the
moment
um and to the best of my knowledge I'm
I'm not sure we've actually done any
kind of submission using all so so I
don't think I'm I'm actually able to
answer this question
I'm throwing all the hard questions at
you right now so the next um what's up
voted here was
uh if SAS wouldn't have raised the
prices by such a high percentage do you
think open source would be less
prevalent in Pharma
so I can give you the go and and yeah we
can compliment as well if you want
um
I think
so there's there's a few things in
things in discussion so there's
definitely the
price of the license that that is
definitely is definitely pricey and and
for some organizations it is an issue
and you know it has a huge impact on our
budget as well so that's one thing
um but I think there's another aspect to
it which is the open source aspect
and as of today
um when you want to consult when you're
when you are reading a paper and when
you want to actually give a try to the
um set second methodology or the new
machine learning methodology
in the form of an r package
um you know some kind of development
some kind of Open Source development and
I think that's a big difference between
between Sasa and all in the sense that
these all the regulatory work
and and still as of today Allah
but then there's all the question about
exploratory and all the questions about
study design if we take the the example
of Designing randomized control files
and then that's where I think the
strength of Open Source plays a big role
um so so I think even even if SARS would
not have raised the prices
um that much I still think open source
will have played a key role in the
pharmaceutical industry
and I think this is also I think it's
also linked to one of the questions that
popped up I think on the YouTube channel
you know constantinos was asking what
are the dangers of using r or open
source languages compared to licensed
languages and I wouldn't call it a
danger you know but I I'll say that uh
when I first did first heard about R you
know I in my PhD used
closed tools I did a news R for any kind
of analytical work that I did during my
PhD it gives you an idea of my age let's
forget about that but I think the
advantage of Open Source that you have a
community you have the experts in a
field developing a solution that is
available to you few months after it has
been developed it's out there you can
use it you can modify it and it is not
the same in environments like SAS like
my Mac lab we don't
particularly I think you have their
Cutting Edge you have the community you
have that support you post a question on
the art community and you know the the
person that has developed the package
answer you doesn't get better than that
in terms of access to expertise and
knowledge so I'm not gonna say that we
all have to ditch known open source
tools but I think it's a great
complement to be able to have that
support uh and be able to move at quite
a fast pace with open source
so
thank you both
okay is it okay I know we scheduled
maybe 15 minutes extra to run over do
you have to run to
a meeting
no that's okay for me yeah okay there's
so many so many great questions
um okay so one of the first questions
actually that came over on YouTube and
you might need to help me with some of
the acronyms here does AZ use r or
python in a GMP environment or is it
just in research business functions
a good overview of all the platforms
that we use
I probably say not an overview of all
the platforms that we use
so so I have been working with um so I
can I can give it a try if you want
um
so I've been in contact with um someone
in um late phase um clinical trials so
late late phase programming in in
randomized control trials
um and this is definitely a Hot Topic
um because if we want to push the uh the
use of R further anastasenica there is
definitely all the piece related to the
training how do we upskill our
collaborators but there is also on the
piece regarding um GXP compliant
environment
um so this is something we are working
on
um and and hopefully in the next few
months we should have an answer to this
thank you
um going back in and touching on the
training aspect somebody had asked what
kpis does your team use to evaluate how
much each course or how successful each
course was
you said we only have 15 minutes
[Laughter]
no I mean I I briefly briefly briefly
touched it when we were looking at those
uh numbers for our training but this is
actually something that I am quite
passionate about even before joining AZ
I was already looking at how to measure
quality and impact of short courses
um in in one of the previous projects
that I was involved in which was
actually pan-european
infrastructure Elixir and you know I
think the way we approach it is right
after the course we would measure the
quality did you like the course did you
think it was balanced are you planning
to use the tools in your future work uh
what did you like the most what did you
like the least you know just to get a
sense of how the course is received and
then at intervals of six months after
the course uh well six months after the
course we will circulate another survey
where we are instead going to ask are
you using the tools
What in what way has the training helped
you and you saw some of the
questions that we asked how has improved
the way you code has improved the way
you collaborate but we also ask
questions around have you actually
passed your knowledge to others have you
train others on how to use the tools so
we do collect some metrics a combination
of quantitative and qualitative although
this type of kpis are often more
qualitative the quantitative we try to
do some quantitation but it's not
perfect
but also we do interviews a round of
interviews with our Learners just ask
them
um you know some people the debt by
survey is definitely something that we
are experiencing so it's nice to do some
case studies uh we have you know
evidence of individuals that are change
roles and we're not in a data science
role and then they have transitioned
into one we have several success stories
uh on how the the the the the training
he's helping so uh we have few sets of
kpis but in some cases it's also just
you know interviews and and talking to
the Learners and see how they've been
affected
great thank you okay we'll take
maybe five more questions if we can get
through them but I'll send you all the
the other questions too and can try and
group them together as well
um but on slido I'm seeing right now the
most uh upvoted is
how did you pick use cases that would
motivate people to want to learn did you
start with specific Technologies to
highlight the power of Open Source data
science like shiny
I think when it comes to use cases uh I
think this is a bit of a
um well
I would say that the success of the
training program is also try to marry
you know what is the need with what is
the availability of the people that are
going to contribute to the training
program let me explain when we when we
work on use cases you know we try to
showcase the work that others within the
organization are doing so we want to
kind of kill two birds with one stone
one is to already display how we're
using data science how we are utilizing
one particular technology uh and how is
that enabling us to achieve particular
goals in a way that you get also to
inspire others and that is where you go
back to the peer-to-peer learning as
well how others are using the skill
within the organization might be
relevant for what I'm trying to do but
at the same time it's also an
opportunity for our subject matter
expert menu which contribute to our
training to Showcase also what they do
so give the them that visibility make
people aware of who are the experts
within the organization so if I have a
problem and I want to talk about natural
language process who do I go and talk to
so I think you know the selection is the
use cases is what is that we think is up
and coming and it's going to be a hot
topic of interest but also where our our
experts and how can we give them some
visibility through showcasing some of
their of their use case of of the work
that they do through these use cases
thank you
okay let's see trying to make sure I got
got to all the ones that uploaded up
there the other one on the training was
how much is a reproducible environments
and workflows taught for all users going
through the training
what I can definitely say that uh
reproducible science you know is very
high on our list we can do better we are
developing more courses that are around
the software best practices and how you
work reproducibly as I said before we
try to get more of our courses run of
our infrastructure so when the training
is over the infrastructure is already
readily available to the user to
continue their work we have recently
done a a a a seminar actually just last
week was an idiom around
workflows
in collaboration with posit so again I
think we definitely need to
expose more of these and get more people
to utilize our environments and adopt
best practices so it is definitely
something on on their eyes how do you
you know containers
and reproducibility and portability is
definitely something that is higher on
my list for for next year budget
permitting
at the end of the year
I can add my Santa wish list no
exactly absolutely
and the the Community Front I know
geometry we were talking a bit about
making things sustainable and I see
somebody had asked can you talk about
why you decided to drop easy tidy
Tuesdays
that's that's a very good question
um it was it was not an easy decision
because it was the first initiative uh
we started and that's what
um built
um quite some momentum around the
community so that was definitely not an
easy decision
um but the reason why we decided to draw
basic attitude is was basically we could
see a drop
um in participation so that was one
thing
and and it was just so the fact that you
know all these initiatives even if you
think that at first they don't take time
they still do take some time because you
know for every single agent I did use
the addition we had to look for a data
set so it was a publicly available
available data set but we still had to
look for one
and we had to frame it around a nice
story
um then you have to select the featured
entry then you have you go through the
code then you select
we were selecting three to five nice
things in the code that we were actually
putting up so that everyone could
benefit so you know it was it was a
matter of time basically
um and it was to to feel a bit of space
a bit of yeah a bit of space a bit of
time for new initiatives
thank you okay two more questions I
promise
um one uh great question over on slido
is are there eight teams in AZ that
include both are only people and SAS
only people if yes how did you manage
them working together
I I think I I can give a go to this one
I think this this is kind of fading away
I would say because
I was saying you know everyone is
becoming multilingual these days
um and and I think it is true and it is
true for the new joiners in the industry
because even if they learned all python
or Julia at University when they join us
was as early career professionals
they
um they have some such training so they
become multilingual in such
now if we take the example of people who
have been with us for a longer period of
time and one more versatile at SARS I
think they are also seeing the the our
journey not only but in the
pharmaceutical industry and and if
people want to remain competitive
they need to learn to use R so this kind
of you know decote me between all only
people or certainly people I don't think
it exists anymore and I I don't think in
the us to come is going to exist because
everyone is is multilingual and everyone
is going to be able to to help each
other out
foreign
initiatives I see Eric had a great
question how do you motivate community
members to share their insights and
learnings in the meetups or other
sessions
that's a great one
um an environment relates to you what we
talked about in the past Rachel when
we're like
I think what is important in communities
is how do you make sure that your
community goes from a receiving mode
to a contributing mode
and and I was just looking like earlier
today at
um our Facebook equivalent group at
AstraZeneca
and I was actually quite happy when I
was scrolling through the feed of of the
group because I was like I could see
questions popping up and posts popping
up so not many posts you know today but
like you know from the past few days and
these posts were not driven by steering
committee members
and and I think that's the hardest bit
maybe
how do you make sure that you create a
we talked about this as one in the past
how do you make sure you create a safe
space
so that everyone is fine being
vulnerable
in such an environment and being like
okay I'm going to be asking a question
maybe maybe it's a simple question but
it doesn't matter
and and I think
that's that's kind of how we
we motivate others we try to create this
safe space so that everyone can speak up
um that's one thing and the other thing
is so
we've got different kinds of initiatives
some of them require uh quite quite a
level of R but some of the other of them
let's say the um lunch and learns we
make sure that we don't over complicate
things
so that it's also open for beginner to
present in a in a few additions and are
very much like what you say which or
when you talk about you know the Journey
of a participant maybe that person is
going to be joining the media first
um not speaking then following Tommy
that person is going to be asking a
question and then the goal is to have
that person present something
at some point
so that's that's what we try to do
and I would say that there is a lot of
enthusiasm though within the
organization for sharing so when when uh
I I was for some reason part of of the
one of the sponsor of the Our Community
Conference and I think there was a lot
of uptake people really volunteered to
participate present co-organize I think
one thing that we have to appreciate and
I didn't when I joined the organization
this is a very vast organization so you
can be an R user you know relatively
isolated in your group trying to do
something not knowing what others are
doing so I think establishing these
these networks and meetings or meetups
people really value the fact that they
can share experience and connect
um so I think the enthusiasm is
definitely there I don't think we need
to do too much motivation
that's a great Point gabri sometimes
people might be worried working in a
team where they don't know about the
community that exists already and
if in the future somebody is watching
this uh Meetup recording on YouTube and
they're from AstraZeneca and they just
started how do they go about finding out
about the community events
yeah as as Yom said you know we have
social media everybody's added to that
social media uh you know we are I'm
personally working on getting more data
science learning onto onboarding so you
know it's all about
raising awareness of what's out there
and what's available so
um I think there are channels for
newcomers to do so but I'm sure we can
improve in that respect as well but
there are various channels through which
that they can become aware
great thank you both so much gabriang
Guion
it's really been great getting to to
join some of the r and Pharma events and
to get to meet you both and work with
you both it's so impressive to see all
the training and community building that
that you both do thank you very much
thank you for the invite
yeah welcome with the pleasure
for
for others listening in I also wanted to
just give you a heads up and I just put
it into the chat too but it's a big
Pharma week for us here because we also
have Christina Fillmore a data science
leader at GSK joining us as the featured
leader at the data science hangout this
Thursday as well so I also just put that
into the chat but want to thank you all
for all your great questions and for
being here and joining us today as well
have a great rest of the day everybody
thank you so much